Hello everyone and welcome to this talk
in open agent uh ecosystem and uh I
would like to call it having an AI
engineer at your fingertips.
Um I'm Marvia and I work in the open
source team of hugging face. How many of
you are hugging using hugging face on
daily basis?
Oh, let's change that. This is not okay.
Um but first let's talk a bit about open
source and what it is. So when it comes
to machine learning, open source is
absolutely differential. Basically you
have the open weight models
um that go in with non-commercial
licenses. we call them open weight and
then we have open source models that
have uh commercially available licenses
such as this one from deepseek it's
called MIT license or Apache 2.0 And
then there is like even more open models
that have the code open. If you have
like agents there, the harness is open,
everything is open. And this matters
even more by the fact that like
yesterday or the other day it was
revealed that the cloud uh performance
was going down. Uh so if you if you have
everything in the open, nothing changes
without you knowing. no performance
degradation without you knowing
everything's great. Uh but on top of it,
if you have access to the weights, you
can shrink them, you can quantise them,
you can fine-tune them if you feel like
it. And it's absolute guaranteed privacy
for your end user because uh you can
deploy it to edge devices, browsers
without the data going somewhere else.
uh this matters a lot in my opinion even
more these days with the security
breaches and everything
and there was this argument maybe few
years ago that open source models aren't
as good as no no this is not the case
like you see for instance the latest GLM
5.1 is absolutely crashing it and I'm
actually using it in my coding setup uh
the this is the uh artificial analysis
intelligence index and the green ones
ones are open models. Meanwhile, the
black ones are the closed models. And we
are we just catched up and we will catch
up even more with the upcoming models
and stuff. And let's go back to hugging
face hub. So everything is facilitated
through hugging face hub. All of the
open releases. It's the inferral layer
for all of your open source uh
workflows.
And as of now, it's hosting even more
models. I should have updated the
number. It's probably close to three
million a lot of data sets spaces and
everything but that's not all when it
comes to the agentic ecosystem and this
is what we are going to talk about
today. So when you go to the models uh
you can filter for aentic models. Uh
they are mostly the trending ones and
there is like two types of models in my
opinion. There is the v vision LMS and
then there is the LLMs and the vision
LMS can also act as like a computer use
agent over the screenshots. They know
where to click etc. which is pretty
cool. And one trend I have recently
noticed is the fact that you have uh
labs releasing their LLMs as vision uh
with vision capabilities day zero like
for instance the Gemma 4 was an omni
model and still it's an agentic model
there is Q1 3.5 uh there is Kimik Kimik
2.5 these were VLMs so I foresee that
all of these models will be over time
release day zero with vision
capabilities
and uh it's super easy to run this
actually like you can just use like VLM
ML or like llama CPP llama server uh
from the get-go with like few lines of
code like it used to be much more um
frictiony but these days this is a not a
big deal
and if you want to compare open models
we have recently launched this feature
called benchmark data sets. So when you
go to the data sets on the left hand
side there is like on the bottom there
is a bunch benchmark button you just
click it and then you can see the
popular benchmarks such as S sw ebench
pro or humanities last exam or aime and
others and when you go to for instance
swb bench to see like how your agent is
like good in coding and stuff uh you see
the open models ranked according to the
scores. So like currently GLM 5.1 is top
of the list.
So it's also easy to pick an open model
these days because there's 3 million
models out there and it used to be a
challenge to pick different models.
And if you actually want to vibe check
it, HuggingFace has this ser uh service
called inference providers uh which does
routing for the best models to best
providers like all of the providers are
there. There's gro cerebras I don't know
and everything and then it's super easy
to compare them as well if you see like
uh you have the cheapest or the fastest
option actually I had to truncate it but
also there is the tool used column so
you can actually pick one of the open
source models for the agentic use case
and stuff and going back to agents after
all of these uh hugging face hub shill
uh hugging face hub actually recently
has shipped a ton of uh features for you
to use open models with agents agents
and stuff and first off like there is
the MCP server where you can plug hub
into your LLM
and there is uh skills uh which allow
you to even wipe train models like you
just go to your agent and say train Q1
3.5 on this data set for me and then it
just trains which to me is like a sci-fi
at this point because it used to not
exist and like there is so many things
going on in the back end and the agent
actually handles them very well. And
then there is the local agent. So you
can run full coding agents uh locally
from models with hugging face hub
because we integrate very well to them.
And coming to the first one so basically
my talk will be consisting about all of
these. Uh coming to the first one, there
is the local coding agents
and your options. You have like actually
many many options but like one of my
favorites is Pi because it's like super
simple to set up. Uh basically you can I
I think you can also use it with
inference providers remotely but also if
you want to serve like a local coding
agent you can use llama CPP to serve it
and then pi will directly consume that.
And uh something very cool is also llama
agent which is baked into llama CPP as a
binary that you can just directly
execute and start a model by giving
hugging face hub ID. So it's super easy
as well to get an local agent running.
Uh I will share my slides on my Twitter
account after so no need to take
pictures.
My one of my most favorite things these
days is Hermes agents and I will just
die on this hill. So this is like this
is a bit one step even further to from
the open claw by means of memory
management and everything and it's
actually super easy to get started with
that and uh it is you can either use it
locally or with hugging face inference
provider. So for instance, I was playing
with that
uh like the setup wizard does everything
for you. You just give the keys and
stuff and then integrate into your Slack
or WhatsApp or whatever and you're good
to go. And I absolutely recommend using
this if you want to use it with an open
model. I absolutely recommend GL GLM
5.1. For instance, I actually failed
initially to integrate into Slack. I
have witnesses in here my colleague uh
Neils this year and um I asked GLM 5.1
to fix it with the Hermes agent and it's
fixed on its own and it's it's uh it was
a good day like uh I I think GLM 5.1 is
a very good model and I cannot I can't
absolutely wait to use it with Gemma 4
but also this weekend there is like on
Twitter there was a rumor ignored uh
minimax model coming up. So I will also
probably try with that and share my
findings. So I absolutely recommend
using her agent with the open models.
And one more thing so basically uh
hugging face hub now has a new data set
repository type called traces. And this
is basically all of your uh codeex uh
cloud code or pi traces they host it.
And for instance if you go to your um if
you pushed uh a trace uh and then you go
over there you will see in the data set
viewer if you click on the traces column
uh it pops up like this. It is very
nicely parsed and you can just explore
your data and then later if you want you
can even train a model on that which is
pretty cool in my opinion.
And uh if you want to push your agent
traces you can just upload your sessions
from uh these uh paths and nothing else
is needed. And we will also probably
have Hermes agent very soon for traces.
uh going back if you want to use if you
want more options to serve LLM behind
the agent locally.
So some tips and tricks in finding a
good model. You just go to hugging face.
There is an other tab. Under the other
tab there is the apps. So these apps are
like lm studio, jean, um, llama, cpp
everything that is for local serving is
over there. And when you filter for
them, you have the models that are
supported by these uh by these uh local
apps. So whatever you want to serve, we
have you covered. And when you go to the
model repository, something very cool in
my opinion is that on the left and right
hand side there is GGUF uh section. So
basically GGF if you don't know it's
supported it's it's basically comes in
llama CPP the file uh format uh that is
supported in many things like all llama
LM studio everything and
you have the hardware compatibility for
instance the Gemma 4 larger model if you
quantize it to 4bit it fits inside an L4
GPU uh with the 24 GB of VRAM.
So I think this is very cool and this is
also served to uh MLX repositories as
well. And when you go to the again to
the model repository if you have
absolutely zero clue on how to serve
this model on top right there is use
this model and you have the options of
the local apps that the model is
supported in. And when you click that
you see like only with few lines of
command uh that you can run you install
you get the model served and voila. It's
very very convenient to run the open
models these days
and lastly supercharging your coding
agents using hugging face skills.
So there is we have like bunch of skills
in order to get you started with
training uh I don't know inferring with
the open models using open models
exploring open data sets using AI apps
everything and uh we have this thing
called hugging face CLI skill which
allows coding agents to manage
repositories
uh run jobs launch demos and everything
and this is how you can install it uh
you can just uh type HF skills on Google
and you will find the uh commands. Uh
but we have more skills than that. So
basically this allows you to plug hub in
into your agents like give you all of
the uh hugging face hub exploration. But
rest of the skills are super cool. There
is LLM trainer skill. Basically this is
uh this is not only for LLMs but also
visual language models. You can just
tell the model to okay train this model
on this data set and it will just kick
off the job remotely uh on our infra or
like locally wherever you want.
And there is gradu skill which allows
you to build demos. And there is hugging
face data set skill which allows you to
uh explore data sets through our data
set viewer API and you can install it
very easily. Again we come with more
integrations. I just put cloud and
gemini here.
So putting this into action for instance
I asked the model uh to I asked cloud
code to say hey can you train qan2vl on
lava instruct mix which is like a vision
language data set and it asked me a few
questions. It said okay which instance
would you like this to go in because you
have multiple options. uh the model
actually like in the back end the agent
actually uh calculates the amount of
VRAM required to run fine-tune that
model in a given batch size and
everything. So it handles everything for
you. It just asks you a few questions.
Okay, what is your validation split?
Blah blah. And then it just launches the
job which to me is absolute sci-fi still
to this day as a person who have been
training models since I don't know
beginning of my career like six six
years
and you at the end you just find your
model on hub
and this is not limited to LLMs and VLMs
I have recently shipped um skills for
for instance training object detectors
or I don't know segmenting model and
everything for vision. It handles for
instance different bounding box types
and everything. You just give the
command and let it handle everything.
And going back to MCP, what do we serve?
Uh we have models, data set spaces,
search for your task, uh semantic search
for spaces. So if you don't know spaces,
it's like the app store of AI. You have
a ton of uh apps over there for
absolutely everything you could see. And
also we have something called jobs which
allows you to kick off uh one of jobs
that ends like uh if it fails or if it
succeeds and you pay for the amount of
time it was up. And also you can query
these apps from MCP like I'm going to
show you shortly. But it plays nicely
with all of your favorite platforms.
And so for instance in here I ask the
model generate image of a bakl lava made
of yarn and then it will call uh the
hugging face of qan image which is an
image generation model hosted remotely
and then it will query that and it will
bring um the output of that. It works
very nice look.
But you need to turn on there is a
setting in the MCP called dynamic
spaces. If you want more options of like
if you want absolutely all of the
spaces, you need to turn that on which
is a bit of bit experimental.
And here is some few ideas that you can
use spaces MCP. Uh but you're absolutely
not limited to those. And tying it all
together, my colleague Neils has built
something I which I found cool so I
wanted to share. So basically on hugging
face hub there is papers and these
papers basically AI related papers. We
want people to be able to ask questions
to these papers or share h but not all
of the papers come with markdown uh
which the model which we can index and
stuff. So we OCR 30 30,000 papers uh
using codecs open OCR models and jobs
all through prompting which is a bit
crazy. So the steps to do that is
firstly pick an OCR model that is cheap
and nice and performance. Ask the LLM to
kick off a processing job and actually
write the code for that and then kick it
off on hugging face infra and then let
the skill set up the instance of hosting
that model and everything without you
going through the pain of the napkin
math and then profit.
So to pick an OCR model you need to um
you need you can go to OCR bench which
is a benchmark data set that I have
previously shown you. The first result
is Chandra OCR but don't be fooled by
this. We have just today shipped a skill
that you can just ask the model okay
what is the best model on OCR for
fine-tuning and it will also make
recommendations around finetuning and
stuff. So if you need like smaller
models etc it will handle everything for
you with this skill. So it's pretty
cool. Check it out. Um once you pick the
model okay we in this case we use
Chandram.
uh we asked model to write the script
and it did and then the agent just does
the napkin math for the instance and uh
calculates the cost of the running job
and everything and then these jobs will
be so so basically these jobs will be
rerun. So we have recently launched this
infra product called buckets which is
like a A3 buckets but much cheaper and
faster
um that you can use with mounting and
yeah basically um you can just use that
and you can get started uh in these
links. I hope you like this talk. Thank
you so much.